>>> IT'S NO SECRET DONALD TRUMP
AND THE FAR RIGHT MEDIA CONTINUE
TO OPERATE AS ONE BIG MACHINE,
CONTINUOUSLY PUSHING OUT FALSE
NARRATIVES, CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
AND THE BIG LIE, ALL THE WHILE
IGNORING ITS IMPACT ON OUR
DEMOCRACY AND DESCENT INTO
FURTHER CHAOS AND PERIL.
SO, WHAT CAN THE REAL NEWS MEDIA
DO TO DISPEL THIS INFORMATION?
I WANT TO BRING IN FORMER FOX
NEWS ANCHOR GRETCHEN CARLSON.
LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT HAS BEEN
COMING OUT OF FOX LATELY AS
TENSIONS BETWEEN UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA ESCALATE.
LET'S LISTEN TO TUCKER CARLSON.
>> WHY WOULD WE TAKE UKRAINE'S
SIDE AND NOT RUSSIA'S SIDE.
SINCERE QUESTION.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FROM THE
AMERICAN PERSPECTIVE -- WHY?
WHO'S GOT THE ENERGY RESERVES?
WHO'S THE MAJOR PLAYER IN WORLD
AFFAIRS?
WHO'S THE POTENTIAL
COUNTERBALANCE AGAINST CHINA,
WHICH IS THE ACTUAL THREAT?
WHY WOULD WE TAKE UKRAINE'S
SIDE?
WHY WOULD WE HAVE RUSSIA'S SIDE?
I'M TOTALLY CONFUSED.
>> WELL, CLEARLY.
UKRAINE IS A DEMOCRACY.
RUSSIA IS AN AUTHORITARIAN
REGIME THAT IS SEEKING TO IMPOSE
ITS WILL ON A VALIDLY ELECTED
DEMOCRACY IN UKRAINE.
WE'RE ON THE SIDE OF DEMOCRACY.
>> YEAH, I GUESS I'M ON THE SIDE
OF DEMOCRACY IN OTHER COUNTRIES,
I GUESS.
>> HOW HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE
PARODYING TUCKER CARLSON'S
PRO-RUSSIAN STANCE.
WHY DO YOU THINK TUCKER DOES
THIS?
AND WHY DO THE MURDOCKS ALLOW
IT?
DO THEY NOT EVEN CARE, OR IS IT
JUST ABOUT MONEY AND RATINGS DO
YOU THINK?
>> RATINGS I THINK FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
BUT THIS IS THE RESULT OF FAKE
NEWS.
WE'RE SEEING NOT ONLY THE
FALLOUT FROM FAKE NEWS DURING
THE TRUMP ERA BUT WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE INSURRECTION ON JANUARY
6th.
NOW IT'S MOVING INTO OTHER
AREAS, NOT JUST NEWS.
NOW IT'S HITTING SCIENCE WITH
VACCINES.
AND NOW IT'S INTO COLD WAR
POLITICS.
I MEAN, THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD
BE TALKING ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
WE SHOULD SUPPORT UKRAINE OR
RUSSIA, THERE WOULDN'T BE A
REPUBLICAN ON THE PLANET THAT
FIVE YEARS AGO WOULD HAVE SAID
THEY WOULD HAVE SUPPORTED RUSSIA
OVER UKRAINE.
BUT THIS IS WHERE WE ARE NOW.
CONSERVATIVE TELEVISION NEWS IS
CERTAINLY NOT THE CONSERVATIVE
NEWS THAT WAS OUT THERE EVEN
JUST FIVE YEARS AGO.
>> YEAH.
IT'S STUNNING.
AND SINCE THE INSURRECTION, YOU
MENTIONED THAT WE'VE LEARNED
SOME BIG NAMES OVER AT FOX WERE
ACTING ALMOST AS ADVISERS TO
TRUMP LIKE SEAN HANNITY AND
LAURA INGRAM.
AND THEN THEIR TEXTS CAME OUT
WHERE, YOU KNOW, IT SORT OF
SUGGESTS THEY KNEW THERE WAS A
PROBLEM INSIDE THE TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE AND THAT PROBLEM BEING THE
PRESIDENT AT THE TIME.
YOU WORKED AT FOX.
DOES THIS SURPRISE YOU THAT FOX
ANCHORS WOULD BE ADVISING A
PRESIDENT, ADVISING A WHITE
HOUSE?
>> NOT NECESSARILY.
I'M NOT SURE THAT IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN ON THE OTHER SIDE AS
WELL, DEPENDING ON WHO HAPPENS
TO BE IN THE OFFICE.
BUT I THINK THE BIGGER STORY
COMING OUT OF THAT IS HOW
DISINGENUOUS IT WAS TO BE
SENDING THOSE TEXTS OF WARNING
WHILE THEN GOING ON THE AIR TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND DOING A
COMPLETE INJUSTICE AND
DISSERVICE BY SAYING SOMETHING
COMPLETELY OPPOSITE AND GINNING
UP THIS WHOLE REACTION THAT IT
WAS JUST FINE AND PATRIOTIC FOR
PEOPLE TO BE THERE ON JANUARY
6th.
YOU KNOW, SLOWLY BUT SURELY THIS
HAS MORPHED INTO IR RAD KATING
ANY OTHER POINT OF VIEW SINCE
THE TRUMP ERA THAT IS NOT JUST
OPINION.
IT'S GONE FROM AN OPINION, WHICH
WAS FINE, TO COMPLETELY
DEVOLVING INTO NONFACT-BASED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND OUTRIGHT
DANGEROUS RHETORIC, IN MY MIND.
AND I THINK IT'S A COMPLETE
DISSERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY.
>> TOTALLY.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN THESE
BIZARRE MOMENTS WHERE WE'VE SEEN
TOP REPUBLICANS LIKE SENATOR TED
CRUZ GRAVELING ON TUCKER'S SHOW.
DID YOU EVER THINK THAT DAY
WOULD COME?
>> NO.
I THINK THIS IS VERY UPSETTING
TO REPUBLICANS ALSO TO BE QUITE
HONEST.
I MEAN, I WISH MORE OF THEM
WOULD HAVE THE COURAGE TO DO
WHAT I DID, QUITE HONESTLY, AND
THEN COME FORWARD AND TAKE ON A
BEHEMOTH.
BUT, LISTEN, FOR THE SAFETY OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND FOR OUR
DEMOCRACY, I WISH MORE WOULD
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT GOING TO END
WELL IN MY MIND.
IT'S REALLY HARD TO CHANGE
PEOPLE'S OPINIONS BECAUSE
THEY'RE ONLY WATCHING WHAT THEY
WANT TO HEAR.
YOU KNOW?
AND THAT'S THE OTHER PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE IN SOCIETY WITH THE
MEDIA RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE'RE SO
SILOED INTO ONLY WATCHING WHAT
WE AGREE WITH.
SO, EVERY DAY, THAT THOUGHT
PROCESS JUST GETS REINFORCED
TIME AFTER TIME.
I MEAN, THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE,
JIM, WHO ACTUALLY WHEN I'M
WALKING THROUGH THE AIRPORT
STILL THINK THAT I WORK AT FOX
NEWS.
>> WOW.
>> BECAUSE -- YEAH.
BECAUSE THEY WATCH ONLY FOX NEWS
AND THEY NEVER COVERED BY STORY
THERE OBVIOUSLY.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHAT
THEY SEE AND WHAT THEY HEAR.
NOW, THAT WORKS ON THE OTHER
SIDE TOO.
THERE'S PROBABLY PEOPLE THAT
ONLY WATCH OTHER NETWORKS THAT
HAVE ANOTHER POINT OF VIEW.
>> TRUE, TRUE.
>> BUT I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
DANGEROUS TO HAVE -- A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HAVING A
CONSERVATIVE OPINION AND HAVING
ONE THAT SUPPORTS CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
>> TOTALLY.
AND DESPITE YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
YOUR DEMOCRACY, YOU ARE TRYING
TO UTILIZE OUR DEMOCRACY TO MAKE
CHANGE.
WEDNESDAY THERE'S GOING TO BE A
HOUSE VOTE ON YOUR BILL, WHAT
YOU SAID WILL BE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN YOUR
LIFE.
DO YOU HAVE THE VOTES?
AND TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ASKING ABOUT IT.
THIS HAS BEEN MY PERSONAL
PASSION OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
SINCE I DID "SOUP BOX NEWS."
I'M TRYING TO GET RID OF THE
SILENCE MECHANISMS, MAINLY
FORCED ARBITRATION FOR ASSAULT
ITSELF THAT KEEPS THESE ISSUES
SILENT IN THE WORKPLACE.
I KNOW YOU'LL LOVE.
THE COSPONSORS ARE SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND SENATOR
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND.
IT MAY BE ONE OF THE FEW THINGS
THEY AGREE ON, BUT THEY'VE BEEN
CHAMPIONS OF THIS.
AND I HAVE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE.
IT WILL BE THE BIGGEST LABOR LAW
CHANGE IN THE LAST 100 YEARS, BY
BIGGEST LIFE ACCOMPLISHMENT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS IS GOING
TO CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE, MAKING
THE WORKPLACE SAFER FOR MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE.
AND I'LL BE INCREDIBLY PROUD
WITH THIS MOMENT HAPPEN.
>> GRETCHEN CARLSON, MY HAT'S
OFF TO YOU.
BRINGING REP